[Musique]
c'est en 1990 que l' aventure signature
commence une agence de com décident de
manger du bitume et se lance dans la
compétition automobile 28 ans après la
petite entreprise a muté en devenant
l'écurie officielle signatech en charge
du retour à la compétition de la
mythique marque alpine 40 personnes y
travaillent à plein temps mais derrière
la bleue de france se cachent des hommes
de l'ombre
passionné c'est peu dire la voiture
c'est le bébé de tous les mécaniciens
ils ont démonté plusieurs fois en pièces
détachées il soigne moindre ne moindre
boulon le moindre détail de la voiture
le moindre fil qui passe dans un dans
une interface de la voiture ils savent
exactement la façon dont ils passent la
façon qu'il est protégé
tout est tout tout doit être maîtrisée
pour minimaliser au maximum le risque de
panne exigeante et performante
la réputation de signatech n'est plus à
faire dans le monde si fermé du
championnat du monde d'endurance bien
sûr elle ne joue pas dans la cour des
grandes marques mais en catégorie lmp2
la plus spectaculaire la plus disputée
le camp de base de signatech se niche au
coeur d'une zone industrielle de bourges
les locaux sont séparés entre plusieurs
ateliers on à l'atelier compétition à
proprement dit c'est sont les programmes
pour lesquels on est engagé tant que
team on a un atelier de carrosserie
également et un atelier plutôt
production dans lequel on fait
principalement de l'assemblage des à 110
actuellement le dérivé de la 110 de
route qui a été dérivé en version
circuit eh oui cerise sur le gâteau
aujourd'hui les petites soeurs de la
vedette numéro 36 sont préparés ici la
version moderne de la prestigieuse
berlinette chacun tient son rôle de
technicien en sport automobile avec un
objectif la performance
chaque pièce qui constitue la voiture
est suivi en kilométrage en fait unités
renom dont chaque pièce a une durée de
vie donc quoi qu'il arrive on fait
tourner les pièces il ya des pièces qui
arrivent à un certain potentiel cirque
on estime qu'elles ont parcouru un
certain nombre de kilomètres et qui ne
sont plus viables pour rouler en course
elles ont encore un petit peu de durée
de vie pour rouler en essais par exemple
en hiver quand on va aller faire des
essais pour préparer l'année suivante
pensé à tout et en même temps gérer
l'imprévu et la logistique
chaque geste compte c'est la signature
de signatech